et pas si elles sont bitumées doha à
west bay dollars j'essaie de mettre
alors c'est vite c'est plus dur j'ai
passé la moitié des rouges terres
nouvelles souches quoi la fois technique
et voilà dans la foi je n'ai que ça
reste un traumatisme vous aimez les
lubies mal non hier sept jours avec les
évidents kennedy
[Applaudissements]
barry baril
si tu me diras tu as gagné tu subis si
tu l'avais pas c'est terminé
tout ça joue maintenant c'est l'action
suspense où se joue maintenant sur cette
canette regarde si je ne mets pas cette
canette dans la poubelle
tu gagneras son euro est prête on fait
ce que tu en veux tu es données bernard
montiel dieu c'est une bonne idée
en revanche si jamais on sera ce qu'on
appelle une mort subite
génial par contre on était un petit peu
plus loin moi j'avais parlé comme s'ils
allaient tension à 6 ans concentration
si tu le prends comme ça qu'ils devaient
nous superviser moi aussi un jour j'irai
à tête non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya donc une mort subite regardez-moi
la gare suivi les chiens aussi j'y vais
partager le premier qui loupe
au début on jouer sans argent y perdre
et qu'on a je sois équipes avaient
barman bas
c'est comme la seule émission potter 8
heures sur les poubelles qui devait
bravo je suis très content parce que ça
me trottait dans la tête cette affaire
mythos moi je travaille justement ça va
faire une belle un jour gris qui pouvait
le mener à montiel ça sinon parce que
c'est pas vraiment de l'argent du coeur
une vie et tu veux passer sur rfm nom de
nadal
[Rires]